from the mercury news just what was your  reaction to the crowds chants that were  directed to you throughout the game  no they just talking um  it's  not really my job to react to them so  they did what i expected  marcus back right  marcus thompson athletic draymond how do  you how do you feel you played like [ __ ]  what was the difference this game i  just think i never found a rhythm  really on both ends of the floor so  not enough force  but  just got to find the rhythm quicker  monty in the middle here draymond what  most disappointed you about the way you  guys played tonight and yourself i was  soft that's what was most disappointing  to me  for us